it starts with a basic truth those we
have buried are not actually dead
they've entered the bar a parallel
existence where there are people right
now that are just as alive as you I was
doing D once in spe's corner and um one
girl came to me and she said I left
Islam I was serous I said like what's
the reason and she specifically
mentioned Gaza this was a couple of
years ago this not even what's going on
now so she was like I left Islam and I
was like okay so it really amazed me
like a thought came to my mind and I was
like wow I and I expressed it to her I
said I said sister don't you think it's
amazing that
you just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope
you how are you good ald so I came in to
see in a specific location we're going
to go into detail of course it's
classified but aldah got a chance to sit
with him speak with him got to know him
better alhamdulillah uh and yeah got
nothing but good to say andah your y
Institute has really helped me in my da
as well when it comes to prophecies I
believe it's prophecies play a great
role like me when it comes to convincing
people to ISL so Allah bless and
preserve
you yes so you've got this serious that
is coming out it's called the other side
yeah so we're going to watch it we're
going to react to it because there's a
lot of lessons to be learned from it
because I found it really powerful so
are you ready to watch yourself see on
the other put my head down
are you sure where are you going and how
do I know I'll make it there what's it
like over there is there a way you can
tell me about it am I viewed amongst the
righteous or the wicked what's real
about what's around me right
now there's this world you're in and
another world that simultaneously exists
that you can't see but it sees you Allah
the angels and other elements of the
Unseen are watching you and you're only
one step away from
it it starts with a basic truth those we
have buried are not actually dead
they've entered the bar a parallel
existence where there are people right
now that are just as alive as you some
of them are watching green birds that
were once in bodies of martyr soar above
them others are drowning in rivers of
blood some are dwelling in beautiful
homes among family members that have
been dead for decades others are busy
being being devoured by beasts with many
heads so what is this realm and what do
we know about the people who reside in
it and what would knowing about that
world do for us today to make sense of
the world we live in right now and what
does it mean for us in our own
individual Journeys trying to find our
way back to Allah
[Music]
w
so subh Allah that was very powerful
from the production to you know
[Music]
explanation what comes to my mind is you
know when we're looking at Gaza I spoke
to you about this yesterday as well I
was doing D Once In The Speaker's Corner
and um one girl came to me and she said
I left Islam I was curious I said like
what's the reason and she specifically
mentioned Gaza this was a couple of
years ago this not even what's going on
now so she was like I left Islam and I
was like okay so it really amazed me
like a thought came to my mind I was
like wow I said and I expressed it to
her I said I said sister don't I think
it's amazing that you are living in the
west you live in some sort of comfort
you don't have to worry about you know
your life being in danger bonds dropping
Etc and yet you have doubted Islam
because of what you see we call this the
problem of evil it's Shad how I said the
very people that you're looking at their
suffering has led you to De Islam is
doing the opposite effect on them they
are the ones that are actually suffering
they're the ones if there's anyone that
we can say could y should be saying what
you're saying is them but they're doing
the opposite
right what would you like say that
because a lot of people are like we l
our da table people are just amazed of
the people in Gaza it doesn't make sense
to them it's like like how does this
woman come pick up the body parts of his
daughter son and say yeah this is Adam's
leg this is and and says alhamdulillah
like I I look at that as a Muslim you
get a disbeliever I look at as a Muslim
and go can I say those words if if that
was my kids and I have a big question
mark on myself and I say I don't know if
I can say that what makes these people
so unique and please tell us this series
what's inspired you to talk about the
[Music]
firstly when Allah subhana describes the
Descent of the Quran as being a means by
which he divides the Believers from the
Hypocrites that it sends some people on
a journey back to Allah subhana T it
sends others on a journey down a very
dark path that it's aan that it's a
Criterion the people of Quran also and
there are no people that can rightfully
be called the people of Quran in the
collective sense like the people of Gaza
today the people of the Quran also
become a means by which you can
distinguish truth and falsehood and
people are sent into different
directions that's not to say that some
very sincere Believers have not
experienced deep pain that they've had
to come to terms with over the last year
and a half and have found themselves in
in a in a place of hardship and uh deep
sorrow to where you know there was a
wesa there was a whisper from the shapon
inside of them I'm not talking about
those people but what I'm talking about
is the fact that because of Gaza you
have people that have embraced Islam at
a rate like we have never seen before
and you have some people who still would
find their way away from Allah subhana t
as a result of this one of the things
subh that that you mentioned which is
very important here the people of Gazza
are not questioning their faith so who
are you to question faith on their
behalf the people that are the core
subject of this that are experiencing
this are not questioning their faith
exactly in fact they are having having
extreme connection to Allah subhana tala
premonitions dreams about the Hereafter
they're renewed in their faith their
resilience that doesn't mean they're not
sad that doesn't mean they're not
devastated at times yes they cry over
their loved ones they cry over the
circumstances that have befallen them
but at no point are they questioning
yeah that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is
putting them through an unnecessary
trial with no reward at the end EX they
understand that they're here for a
purpose you see if you're born and
raised in Gaza you know from the very
beginning that you're here for a very
reason and that you occupy a very
special purpose in this world and here's
the thing Subhan Allah these people are
not limited by What's called the open
air prison of Gaza because they're
already connected to a Jenna that is
broader than the heavens and the Earth
they are not intimidated by their human
oppressor because they're already
connected to the lord of the oppressor
and the oppressed they already are
connected to Allah subhah wa taala in
all of his glory and so you can't
restrict them and so when Allah subh
says that whoever turns away from my
remembrance will have a constricting
life yes we can see that that people
have Suffocation yeah despite their
great circumstances you know forget
about people leaving Islam because they
can't come to terms with devastation of
the people of Gaza or the refugees of
the world people that leave Islam
because they didn't marry the person
they wanted to marry or they didn't get
the job that they wanted or they didn't
get into medical school or you know in
their full Delight in their full Comfort
they still find a way away from Allah
it's a constricting lifestyle people
that can't find happiness because they
don't have purpose the opposite of that
is true and this is a principle in our
Dean that things are known by their
opposites as well that the more you
remember Allah subhana tala the more
there is the more expans there is and so
these are people of VI these are people
of Quran and they are connected to Allah
so they feel expans even though they're
in this tight circumstance and that's
why you watch a person let's not just
talk about the people in the genocide
you watch the prisoners or you know
let's not call them prisoners a topic
for another day you watch the hostages
the Palestinian hostages that come out
after having been in captivity for 30
years and have missed the death of their
parents the birth of their children and
they still say alhamdulillah as soon as
they come out and they say despite
everything we've been subjected to they
never forgot alhamdulillah they never
forgot Allah subhana so faith is not
something that can be explained easily
to someone who's never touched it or
been touched by it and so the people of
Gazza are a phenomenon to a people that
don't have faith because they don't
understand how these people still have
purpose and on top of that and this is
what you mentioned about
us faith is also something that we pray
that Allah consider us amongst his
devout servants and Believers and grant
us a high state of IM and certainty and
so we can be like the people of in this
regard we have read about the stories of
the sah we've read about these stories
and episodes from
the we've read about the people of the
Quran but to see it exemplified so
clearly in the people of Gaz has made
the story of H so much more real has
made the story of
so
real how many are there how many are
there how many are
there bless him this man who lost every
single person or not every single person
but I mean Subhan Allah his his wife his
children his mother I mean he's lost so
much in this genocide you go and you sit
with this man and he says
ald says my family went to Jenna and I
went to Doha that's how he explains you
know the way that Subhan Allah that this
happened you know they went one where
place and I went another place and Allah
subhana has destined victory for the
people of was and Allah has destined
Paradise for all of us so that's what
this is all about and the other side was
not meant in any way to serve as a
sedative as a means of making us
complacent with the situation of and
saying oh it's okay Allah has taking
care of them in the Hereafter but it's
so that we could renew our spirit and
this is something talked about in the
series that when the prophet talked
about
the when Allah subhana raised them to
him and gave them what he gave them
after their shahada they asked to come
back and speak to their families or to
send the message to their families not
that don't cry I'm okay but they did not
want the Believers to lose heart they
wanted them to keep at it to say we're
okay so keep at it we're okay so keep at
it you have to keep at this that you're
on Continuum that we didn't die for
nothing that we didn't live for nothing
that we had a purpose of living and now
our death has a purpose and you have to
keep it going you have to live with
purpose and die with purpose as well and
so the other side uh I started writing
the series actually in
2023 um I filmed it October
2024 uh and you can just go back subh
October 2024 was a very difficult month
and October 2023 obviously everything in
between like so I I literally was
filming this a year of genocide with a
year of genocide and I was writing it
from the genocide onwards and the idea
was what makes the Barak so profound is
that we we think about like Divine
Justice as a future concept like maybe
it'll happen in the future yeah but
Divine Justice is already happening
because the people that have been
martyred are already receiving their
reward from Allah and every Tyrant that
goes into that realm is already
receiving their punishment yeah so it's
not even about the future it's about the
fact that this exists right now and then
lastly we have to also think about the
fact that we too will go to that place
and the Barak is right right in front of
us it's not the grave is right there it
is it is and the thing is that the
prophet said you know he pointed out a
boy who died and he said his his day of
judgment started yes you because the
moment you die we see it as um far away
Etc you know there's two things we
haven't been told it's our death and the
day of judgment you know because we know
these things uh we'll be behaving very
differently and that's the reason Allah
has told us when we're going to die and
when is and because we need to live like
it could happen tomorrow abely you know
we should live like we're going to die
tomorrow you know different people take
that in a different way YOLO um we take
that as well yes you only live once
meaning and I have to do the best of my
ability to do as much righteous deeds
and talk about situation of Gaza get
still oppressed so yeah it's it's Subhan
Allah it's very very profound and I
think every day in Ramadan it's coming
out yeah so it's going to be like um the
first first uh 10 days is is basically
someone that's outside of the bar and
trying to understand through visiting
the grave through dreams through seeing
genocide through trying to reckon with
the bar and then actually the the last
20 days are you yourself going into the
B and so when you're experiencing the
punishment of the Grave or the reward of
the Grave when you're experiencing
meeting people once again and stuff like
that so usually when I do a Ramadan
series I start with like the you know
the fast pace and then I go into
trying to feel what's outside of it and
that's sort of the the way that the
prophet described this D or the insan he
drew this rectangular shape sallallah
alaihi wasallam and he said this is man
and then he drew a line through it and
he he said that this is his a this is
his uh so this is his lifespan and this
is these are his hopes in this world and
so he showed sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that the hopes of the world extend
outside of the actual lifespan that you
have and then he drew little
lines around that line to show that
these are the tests that you will face
and so you're literally in a box of dya
and until you can see outside of it or
feel outside of it then you're going to
feel exactly as it's drawn which is like
you're boxed in and suffocating and so
it'll be something that um hopefully you
know Shadow B will probably try to
attempt because it has a lot of in it
but hopefully it
it a way for people to to grow and
connect brother sisters you guys can
watch that on y Institute Channel
brother and sisters Mak make the most I
am in planning on doing that as well in
till next time
[Music]